à nice une mère de famille va être
expulsé de son logement hlm car son fils
de 19 ans a été condamné pour trafic de
stupéfiants c'est un fait rarissime en
france la question qu'on se pose ce soir
c'est faut-il sanctionner les parents de
délinquants et on aura dans un instant
en face time ce jeune thomas voilà donc
qui a été sanctionné et dont les parents
étaient sanctionnés il sera avec nous
c'est vraiment une exclusivité totale et
il peut pas se brouiller pouvez pas
déplacer parce qu'il a un bracelet
électronique voilà donc forcément il n'a
pas pu venir de voir mais nous parlera
en face time alors on va parler de ça et
c'est vrai que c'est la grande question
que tout le monde se pose faut-il
sanctionner les parents de délinquants
on avec nogent beitia dont c'est
l'anniversaire et président de
l'institut apollon mais a ainsi fait
vous avez prévu pas pour votre
anniversaire danse et surtout on dort
d'accord
merci
voulez danser les manger
oui
il avance et du rail
c'est vrai bref c'est vrai merci en tout
cas jean bessière et bon anniversaire
tard louis xi un ami maire de poissy
merci d'être là car on se connaît bien
dans le groupe canal + 1 voilà et vous
avez fait les belles heures du groupe
canal+ et aujourd'hui vous fait les
belles heures de la ville de poissy
merci karl et si tu as besoin de moi sur
un truc bien entendu tu n'hésites pas je
serai là m eyrignoux qui est avec nous
merci m c'est la première fois que vous
venez dans l'émission vous êtes
l'avocate de la famille expulsée que
c'était important pour nous que vous
soyez là que vous nous exposer un petit
peu comment ça s'est passé et votre
votre point de vue et vous êtes à côté
de quelqu'un que j'aime le fait qu adama
kamara rappeur et acteur de terrain qui
fait énormément pour les banlieues j'ai
eu la chance d'aller le voir et on a
passé un après-midi ensemble on a kiffé
drogue maintenant on a fait un foot
ensemble je vais fait un centre de fou
quand il m'a plus jamais
[Rires]
bonjour j'ai fait le match de ma vie il
prend et reprise de volée mais on gagne
en plus c'est le but
c'est ça les amis alors on aura avec
nous thomas dans un instant bien entendu
mais pour le moment poutine sanctionner
les parents d'élèves je suis la question
vraiment que tout le monde s'est posé
ces derniers jours tant qu'art karl
olive vous pensez quoi vous moi je pense
que avant à voir la sanction il ya la
prévention avant la prévention il ya la
règle est la règle il faut qu'elle soit
connue par par l'ensemble c'est comme
dans le sport sert il lorsque vous êtes
dans le jeu vous êtes dans le jeu il n'y
a pas de problème quand vous êtes hors
du jeu vous football ya une sanction
mais sanctionner les parents c'est pas
plus ses parents de délinquants que
l'ensemble des départs en maintenant
lorsque l'éducation elle démarre pas
seulement à l'école elle démarre au jeu
aussi à l'endroit des parents on a tous
aient été éduqué delà de la même manière
et si on a un pour cent dans les
quartiers populaires comme c'est
généralement généralement le cas qui
viennent polluer
99 % de l'ensemble de la population à un
moment donné il ya un déséquilibre donc
c'est affaire de réciprocité mère de
famille qui va être entre les trois
langues officielles m parce que son fils
de 19 ans a été condamné pour trafic de
stupéfiants vous vous cautionnez c'est
sûr ça en fait on est on vous jouez de
consoles sur la série de drames précis
non je ne cautionne pas forcément je dis
simplement que avant cela il ya des
discussions à voir avec la famille c'est
à dire en amont il ya de la prévention
il ya des travail il ya du travail de
terrain qui peut être fait que les
associations spécialisées comme la
prévention que monsieur camara peut
évidemment faire et vous savez la fois
dernière quand je suis venu chez vous
c'était pour ce sujet sur la suspension
ou la suppression des aides non
obligatoire je suis allé voir à leur
demande les associations de mamans
isolées dans nos quartiers populaires
elle venait à me dire exactement la même
chose simplement aidez-nous en amont
notamment avec les prévention
spécialisée notamment par exemple avec
des tiges des travaux d'intérêt général
antilles et à poissy il est capable de
donner à la clé deux de l'emploi on est
toujours dans un contrat gagnant gagnant
mais ce la règle n'est pas respectée on
est en dehors du jeu alors on va avoir
je voudrais qu'on ait la vie de deux
mètres et renew vous êtes l'avocat de la
famille expulsée ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer la décision du tribunal la
décision du tribunal est un peu
particulière je veux dire moi c'est la
première fois qu'il ya des saisons comme
ça c'est la première fois qu'il ya une
décision comme ça qui est portée comme
ça dans la presse et qui les taux courts
à jouer
décision comme ça peut-être qu'il y en a
d'autres ce qui me concerne c'est la
première fois c'est la première fois
qu'on le voit tout à fait en trente ans
d'exercice est la première de ce joueur
or maintenant elle est basée sur sur la
jouissance paisible
dulieu louer donc en fait le locataire
doit de par son bail jouir paisiblement
de son appartement en l'occurrence et un
logement social donc et si effectivement
il y a des gens qui troublent cette
jouissance dans le cadre fola mais c'est
la réalité en face et la loi dans le
cadre effectivement du bain
at elle averti
donc voilà ça peut effectivement
conduire à des problèmes des mises en
des mises en des mises en demeure par
effectivement le bailleur donc encore en
l'occurrence c'est côte d'azur habitat à
nice mais effectivement au pire des cas
il peut y avoir après des actions
résignation elle est irrévocable à
manger finalement on en a interjeté
appel bien évidemment d'abord messi
alors justement quand vous faites appel
est-ce qu'ils doivent ils doivent être
expulsé tout de suite ou alors oui on
l'a dit ce qu'on appelle non alors
combien c'est une exécution provisoire
il faut faire une suspension de
l'exécution devant le premier président
de la cour d'appel pour tout vous dire
moi j'ai fait appel la semaine dernière
parce que cette décision a été prononcée
fin juillet et elle a été signifiée le 9
août m s'ils trouvent un totem
d'immunité à ce qu'ils
voudraient bien qu'il trouve quelque
chose d'autre ou qu'on puisse peut-être
proposer quelque chose d'autre alors on
appelle le provost ce jeune de 19 ans
qui a été condamné pour trafic de
stupéfiants et donc la mer va être
expulsé de son logement hlm est ce que
vous comprenez s'agit berne et vous ne
comprenez pas non pas du tout en france
on n'est responsable que de ses propres
actes et là on va expulser une famille
condamnée à travers son fils une mère il
ya beaucoup de réactions mais bien sûr
mais en fait et karl olive suis très
étonné de votre mot l'aise sur le sujet
vous êtes pour la loi pour un maire
puisque normalement c'est impossible de
condamner la mer qu'on n'a pas le droit
qu'est ce qui se passe en réalité le
gagnant de social il va aller fouiller
juge le bailleur social va fouiller dans
le passé judiciaire maintenant des
familles qui habitent des hlm et le
bailleur il va décider grâce à ça si
s'est maintenue tiens cette famille elle
m'ennuie elle ne paye pas je la vire
donc franchement cyril parce que c'est
important c'est scandaleux parce que
c'est une intrusion dans la vidéo ceux
qui disent oui je vais d oui c'est will
valérie vd alors oui moi je pense que
oui mais ça doit pas être systématique
ça doit être une étude au cas par cas
réglé je parle pas non plus c'est un
affront majeur mais surtout les enfants
mineurs quand les parents sam sciemment
que l'enfant passe toutes ses soirées
jusqu'à minuit 1h du matin dehors devant
l'immeuble etc ou dans la maison comme
ça sachant que c'est le lieu où on peut
faire des conneries la nuit etc ils le
savent ils laissent faire et bassement
fait sanctionner mon fils à mon fils qui
est pas un bad boy il a fait des
conneries un moment à soi était bourré
voilà c'est trop dur il a fait des
conneries c'est vers moi qu'on s'est
retourné et j'en ai payé les
conséquences y avait des frais j'ai payé
la des pneus crevés j'ai payé la pac
crever 4 notre voiture parfaitement
débile pas c'est moi qui ai payé et
passa pas
la dernière
ce qui m'agace pardon jean-mi c'est
qu'on se parle entre petits bourgeois
quelqu'un qui a fait quelque chose la
réalité c'est quoi c'est que c'est
certainement une pauvre dame qui est
dans une cité qui est peut-être femme de
ménage qui a du mal à joindre les deux
bouts elle peut plus occuper son gamin
avait pas tout le temps derrière lui
c'est difficile c'est une ville très
compliqué donc elle donc oui
effectivement elle peut pas être
responsable de ce gamin qui est en
perdition qui est un échec scolaire elle
n'a pas d'argent mais bon voilà c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas eu lieu où tu as fait ce que
dit mathieu et effectivement il faut une
flamme et vous êtes pour vous alors oui
parce que parce que je pense qu'il faut
mettre des paliers et les paliers dizy
blement vous allez m'expliquer m si je
sais j'ai des bonnes informations mais
dans cette affaire là n'est pas lyon et
amy c'est à dire que visiblement on nous
dit en tout cas dans les articles de
presse ong lui qui a eu trois ans de
main tendue envers cette famille trois
ans de procédure trois ans où on a dit
attention il ya des dégradations
attention dans le hall de l'immeuble la
famille pose des problèmes attention et
c est au bout de trois ans on dit bah là
on est au bout du bout du bout de la
procédure on n'a plus d'autre choix que
de vous dire au revoir donc juste sur ce
point là est ce qu on me roy est ce
qu'on a raison ou pas par alors est-ce
que voilà il ya des festivals et aviez
alors mais dans la presse je peux taper
rhodia merci ce qui a été dit
effectivement dans la presse il ya du
vrai et il ya du faux déjà on s'est
trompé de quartier 1 c'est pas du tout
le quartier qui étaient mentionnés au
départ donc il a fallu faire un
correctif les trois ans
moi mon client n'a jamais été condamné
pour dégradations il n'y a jamais eu
aucune plainte qui a été déposée pour
dégradations toutes les autres choses
qu'on peut lire dans la presse est faux
il ya certaines choses qui sont fausses
oui mais ça c'est faux c'est du bruit
est aujourd hui d avertissement avant
ils ont ils ont eut reçu des lettres
enfin on m'a transmis attendait parce
que c'est pas si simple
les trois amis non mais on m'a transmis
lors du passage devant le juge de
proximité puisque initiale avant c'était
le tribunal d'instance maintenant ses
juges de proximité on a transmis un
dossier dans lequel effectivement il
semblerait qu'il y ait eu je dis bien
des courriers qui aurait été adressé
deux courriers qui ont été adressés à 7
$ m réalité sinon en garde oui oui mais
sur des faits qui n'ont jamais été
avérée oui mais même à damas ils avaient
déjà été condamnées non pour rien non il
a été condamné au tribunal pour enfants
pour des faits de vols à bas vous dit
non mais si oui c'est bien non non mais
pas du tout dans le cas de pas à pas
dans le cadre de ce carré nations de
l'himalaya à rien nous sommes la seule
condamnation qu'il a eu c'est en tant
que majeur et non pas en tant que mineur
c'est pour ça que c'est quand même
important de souligner c'est en onze ans
mais 2020 pardonnez moi pour un petit
trafic de stupéfiants je dis bien un
petit trafic de stupéfiants ce qui n'a
pas fait un jour de prison un film x est
la raison pour laquelle aujourd'hui
on rappelle l'histoire il se
dit qu il va il sera avec nous tout à
l'heure en personne il peut nous parler
y voit la cia il n'a pas parlé 1 pour
l'instant doctement va savoir ce qui
s'est passé et on rappelle donc cette
affaire c'est une mère de famille va
être expulsé de son logement hlm car son
fils de 19 ans a été condamné pour
trafic de stupéfiants est ce que vous
comprenez cette décision oui moi dans ce
cas très précis je la comprends pas je
comprends pas la décision parce que non
mais faut que
j'ai nommé major est plein il peut
endosser tous toutes ces lézards donc
ses responsabilités
la maman n'a pas lieu d'être au sein de
cette affaire en revanche pour les
mineures mais c'est complètement normal
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui la
délinquance elle est dû à quoi elle est
due à l'éducation est lé duo
fréquentation l'éducation comme l'a dit
très bien mr n'est pas si ça commence
dès la naissance donc là soit on fait de
la prévention soit après on en assume
les conséquences et c'est aux parents
d'assumer les conséquences parce qu'un
mineur aujourd'hui on fait quoi on peut
pas le mettre en prison les rues
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on
fait alors s'il fait siffler un acte
civil s'il fait autre chose qu'est ce
qu'on fait alors on va voir on va voir
des pions dans la ferme et juste avant
oui j'en mets n'ont pu mettre vous
défendez votre client est tout à fait
normal enfin je connais en tout cas que
la suisse y sont mais pas de bracelet
avec tronic à quelqu'un qui a distribué
de trois barrettes de shit c'est quand
même plus importants que ce nous surtout
à une annonce je peux vous dire avec la
politique de la ville et la politique de
la ville sombre après cela tout le monde
tu vas leur pomme banane eu cet arbre
je veux dire c'est une politique
sécuritaire et une réaction tout à fait
normal qu'ils aient une politique
sécuritaire mais là c'est pas du tout
problème à l'heure actuelle il ya des
mecs en prison à vie c'est que
j'ai pris devant à la demie soit
d'accord il j'ai pris mon choix sur une
ballade niçoise voilà ma de j'ai pris
deux piges
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
quand on fait effectivement un gros
trafic de drogue on va directement en
prison ouais d'accord la
royale à voir alors s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît est vrai qu'on revienne aux
sujets jambes et c'est on donnera la
parole à carte vous vous comprenez cette
décision bien entendu bah oui parce
qu'en fait je pense que notre sauce
amélie hui lui les pièces à lui un gars
société se dérègle parce qu'on manque de
bon sens en vue d'un rachat était en
retard à l'école m
je vois famille mais je vois qu'on
veuille en violet on a 3 5 millions de
demandeurs de hlm par an en france et
non seulement 500 milles qu'ils
obtiennent un logement et qui ont la
chance de l'obtenir parce qu'ils payent
un loyer moins cher que le marché et
c'est la collectivité qui finance donc
j'estime ça parfaitement normal que
quand on est indigne de cette libéralité
que vous accorde la société est bien ce
qu'ils foutent le bordel et qui foutent
la merde dans un immeuble doit être
foutu dehors tout simplement c'est pas
la mer
répondez lui dire oui pardon c'est pas
la mer qui indignent là je vous prends
je comprends aisément finir conscient
que mes parents je comprends quand quand
il s'agit de mineurs effectivement ce
qui n'est pas le cas la baisse quand il
s'agit de mineurs et donges d'avancé
c'est vraiment les parents sont
responsables de leurs enfants alors moi
je comprends l'argument qui a été donné
il ya un instant c'est à dire c'est une
mère seule une famille monoparentale qui
galère est arrivé et qui se retrouve
face à un fils même qui peut alors dit
scellé samedi passé lyon qui fait un
mètre quatre-vingt kita molosses équipe
est qu'elle peut pas tenir tout à fait
mais dans ce cas là l'état doit la
priver de son éducation parents parental
mettre ce jeune dans une maison de
redressement raison pour éviter des
faits en fonction de la gravité des
faits et à ce moment là effectivement on
règle comme ça le problème ne peut pas
s'ils voulaient d'un côté la
collectivité peut pas payer deux fois
elle peut pas payer en donnant des
allocations en donnant un logement à une
mère et d'un autre côté payé aussi pour
les conneries fait le jeune a un moment
faut que la collectivité aussi elle
tranche quoi fall du nom mais c'est
gênant honnêtement on peut pas condamner
une dame alors pour elle on va faire
court le met dehors peut briller à une
famille de cinq enfants on les met
dehors c'est bruce c'est fou c'est fou
un célèbre sa paix la fraternité on va
faire ça c'est impossible dans notre
pays donc tu laisses des trafiquants
droits humains qui déconne mais
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on en sait en
effet que cette famille a aussi des
parents qui participent à l'iccat qui
cache le le butin de leur enfance était
rentré
et au niveau
sécurité des makrouts pendant
la pause bouder les yeux tes couilles de
quatre
continents on aimerait vous dit on va
appliquer au cas par cas drg coiffure la
wii on met dehors louis et pas l'autre
merci c'est infaisable
richesse qui aux pme
est intéressant en attendant il ya
quelqu'un qui ne chantait
retirez vous plaît on a des invités bah
oui moi je pense que la suppression les
super simple effectivement dans le cas
de complicités parental oui ils doivent
être sanctionnés par le cas de la
complicité parental de parents qui sont
complètement dépassés
j'avais beaucoup mal et vendre des
fleurs avec
oh là là
ça me choque un peu de ce qu'on dit
parce qu'on met souvent la
responsabilité des parents moi j'ai
qu'une chose à dire c'est que on a une
tête mais on a deux visages à la maison
peut se comporter correctement montrer
aux parents que ça va on a le visage du
quartier vanessa et même souvent on dit
oui les parents ils bénéficient du
trafic de stups mois jérémy parce que je
suis dit c'est que c'est vrai ça c'est
vrai ce qui dit vous avez eu deux
visages
poursuivre poursuivre en fait j'ai
rencontré même des jeunes souvent qu'ils
mentent à leurs parents qu'ils leur
disent ils sont chauffeurs hubert hubert
it means en scooter il livre alors
qu'ils jill et
les parents et les paroles sont pas au
courant ils le savent fort bien sûr donc
après on dit j'aime un peu comme
isabelle qui dit il faut savoir si le
parent les parents sont complices ou pas
oui parce que pour moi les quartz sont
pas complices au contraire comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure et des
familles monoparentales
il ya les personnes vous vous
sanctionner directement les expulse pour
qu'on les aide pas faut les aider on
écrit ce
que j'ai dit il ya énormément de il ya
énormément énormément de mamans qui se
retrouvent seules attirons bertelli de
la réserve vous y êtes on donne c'est de
jeter les gens de minutes pour moi ça
est ce que ta logique que vous avez le
voisinage aussi voilà la loi il n'y a
pas si je suis
aussi normalement en fait quand on a un
problème on vit on vit en démocratie on
est ensemble normalement conduire à ces
canaux
mais qu'on parle de ce cas précis
vraiment voilà parce que c'est ce qui
intéresse les téléspectateurs et
dites-nous c'est aussi un cas qu'on
rencontre évidemment je pas dire au
quotidien mais pas loin en qu'elle en
aucun cas les parents ou bien est ce
qu'il faut c'est
d'abord série là on est un pays des
droits de l'homme mais virgule et aussi
des devoirs mais donc on en a on a des
droits pour tout le monde il ya aussi
des devoirs en face parce que toutes
celles et ceux qui nous écoutent ce soir
je pense qu'elle est une immense
majorité qui va comprendre ce qui se
passe là c'est à dire que j'ai appelé
des bailleurs [ __ ] et des collègues
maires j'ai appelé des préfets qui me
disait longtemps qu'on n'a pas on n'a
pas eu ce type de fermeté et je pense
que c'est un message que qui envoyait
une fois qu'on a dit ça donc ça que je
pense que vous met une fois mis dehors
non à damas je pense que la maman la
maman si effectivement elle n'a pas de
responsabilité par rapport à cela alors
elle peut très bien voir un dialogue
avec le bailleur et je crois que c'est
ce qui a été fait a été fait pour
qu'elle puisse être relogés peut-être
dans un autre quartier alors on fait c
est qu en norvège le déterminera et faux
quand on fait cette expérience là on
s'aperçoit petit à petit un peu moins de
deals dans ce qui s'est passé
adamo
déjà messia tout à l'heure c'est
hallucinant c'est vraiment la ram n'a
pas été condamnée elle n'a pas été
condamnée elle donc l'agent mais ça vous
vous soupçonnez vous qu'elle puisse être
complice
mais elle ne les poussons les périls
averti il a été averti m elle n'a pas
été en reste il s'avère bien les séries
ça n'a rien à vos frais c'est un
avertissement ça n'a rien à [ __ ] a été
condamné en mai sial et là vous jeter
aux orties vous virer une mère de
sécurité condamnent et avertit
les innocents des bancs du lycée rien ça
c'est rien de le
dire moi je dis que vous avez raison sur
sur le sur le fond mais en même temps ce
jeune vit chez sa mère
c'est le jeu des fadas mais on fait
excuser
pour rebondir là dessus elle a été
averti j'ai effectivement des courriers
qui ont été en voilà un qui n'ont pas
été envoyées en recommandé avec accusé
réception
oui mais je suis désolé ça se fait avec
elle les a reçus non parce que si
longtemps qu'elle est suivie et commencé
dans ces quartiers là ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'il ya des gros problèmes
de distribution de quartier pour y être
mais là
encore son pic mais là on n'est pas au
tribunal m oz assez d'être
enfin reçu s'il vous plaît on a la
chance d'avoir casimir avec nous
mais il ya un amalgame qui est terrible
en fait on est en train de transformer
une personne qui est complètement
innocente hors la loi imaginez pour
sanctionne pénalement c'est pareil on va
là sociaux n'est pas un motif pour
braquage pour trafic de drogue non pour
être le parent d'un enfant délinquant ça
n'a aucun sens cela n'avait déjà rien
que ces gens ont une vie très difficiles
on veut encore compliqué là mais c'est
n'importe quoi c'est surtout ce qui est
hallucinant c'est qu'en fait on parle de
cet enfant en disant que c'est un enfant
des quartiers de la maman est
responsable parce que c'est une dame qui
dans un quartier mais moi demain je peux
perdre le contrôle de mon fils mais sans
problème je n'habite pas dans le
quartier ça veut dire quoi ça tombe ça
c'est non mais non mais c'est croire au
30 mai ce sera vous qualifiez vous
perdez pas en 38 sec il est vrai qu'il
est mineur ce sera votre mémoire du tout
d'avoir une famille mr biya y avait pas
l'eau quand des enfants ces fossiles à
l'usiné n'est pas viable et pas du tout
mais plein d'histoires qu'elle jouera
les
investisseurs mais qui sait quand ils
sont en train de dire que le christ est
le chemin on apprend de dire que la
ville en question fait rentrer comme ça
le soir en prenant à la pyrrhus obtient
on va les virer mais je pense qu'à une
enquête ils ont des bonnes raisons ce
que vous dites que c'est la première
fois au monde en français le savent je
sais qu'ils ont bien une et 1000
dossiers très sérieux pour justifier
alors s'il serait très bien appeler une
exacte et
thomas
qui est donc le jeune homme dont la
meilleure va être expulsé au bac avec
nous alors on l'a on leur connaît pas
trop
voilà ça peut être mais pour ceux qui le
connaissent il reconnaît sur le passé
thomas bien sûr qui souhaite garder
l'anonymat comme
s'apprêtait de
sa mère doma merci en tout cas d'el hri
dommage s'il vous plaît souple et mettre
votre problème merci
merci thomas d'être là votre mère a été
expulsé est-ce que vous pouvez nous
raconter ce qui s'est passé dans cette
affaire
alors quand sept mois ce qui nous
projeter le cd dégradation des actes de
vandalisme on parle de trappes est né ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que
trafic des chiffres et des gens c'est
vrai quand j'étais mineure c'est vrai
que tu fais de 3 bitches
donc quand on habite dans un match jelen
c'est vrai que ça justifie pas mais
moi très tôt on sera pas avant le match
à la télé cox ma mère avait des
problèmes de santé
et ce n'est pas en raison d'une hausse
et on et subvenir aux besoins de ma
famille de ma mère surtout
bien sûr bien sûr qu'il n'est pas du
tout d'accord je comprends pas comment
il met recourir
encore avec thomas thomas avoue éric
racine des cheveux vous en êtes vous lui
auprès de votre maman
qu'est ce que cous de ma mère oui est ce
que vous pouvez dire quoi vaguement vous
êtes vous l'avez dit maman je suis
désolé qu'est ce qu'on vient v10
bien sûr bien sûr je suis terriblement
désolé je pensais pas que quelques
bêtises bon des bêtises comme
es15
est ce que cette décision thomas va pas
faire que brèves maintenant vous voulez
vous dire je veux pas [ __ ] ma merde
dans la merde
bien sûr
j'y ai pensé je trouve que c'est
scandaleux
moi je trouve que moi j'ai été puni par
en montrant le trafic que gekko mais je
suis sous bracelet électronique
j'ai pris 20 mois dont dix de sursis et
10 e en aménagement avec le prince
litronic donc tu vois pourquoi m de
sélectionner de mes actes
surtout que moi c'est gentil méchant que
ça mais payez donc maintenant on sait
pas comment on va sûrement être fixé
est ce que si vous saviez que votre mère
aurait pu être expulsé allait être
expulsé ce que vous auriez continuer à
attirer ou à faire des dégradations avec
la vérité bien sûr que non mais bien sûr
que jamais de la vie je pense que tout
enfant hockey nord-américaine sa famille
jamais jean mes origines et en sachant
que sa mère un jour s'ils furent
expulsés parce qu'on sait très bien que
c'était bien qu'ils vont durer voilà
c'est pour manger pour dépanner un peu
sa maison seulement comment mme
herremans elle était jamais ou courante
donne en tout temps pensé que ce travail
je me suis votre mère votre mère est
bien sûr que non elle vous envoie thomas
avoue adéquat avec maman
obama dit
dans magic en gros on avait toujours
prévenu elle m'avait dit que de parfaire
bitches m'en vais devoir avait toujours
nié en dehors de match et je vous assure
que c'est vrai à chaque fois avant de
sortir tout en prévenant rue disent stop
léger pas de bêtises reste pas trop dow
est rentré
dans ma aujourd'hui on est tous très
très triste pour votre maman parce que
et on se dit c'est vrai moi je me mets à
tapas je me dis mais qu'est ce que j'ai
été content de lui dire que j'étais
content j'ai mis ma mère dans la merde
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'elle va faire
comment elle va elle va vivre où vous
allez vivre ou
bien sûr jamais à qui ça va revenir fort
que moi j'entends sans
le trafic de stupéfiants et noir
toujours existé d année en année de
famille en famille
voilà si on devrait vraiment guéri tout
le monde parce que leurs enfants
profiter un jour en sortie de banc
thomas regarde mine de rien regarde
regarde ce que tu nous as dit ok hyper
intéressante a dit un truc tu as dit si
j'avais su que ma mère se serait fait
expulser j'aurais pas dit les j'aurais
pas fait de conneries donc in de feu il
ya plein de gens qui étaient des gens
qui doivent nous regarder soi qui
doivent se dire c'est quand même la
bonne solution qu'est ce que tu en
penses
mais moi je trouve que c'est pas normal
qu'une averse yeux les offres de son
fils surtout qu'elle n'était pas au
courant ma mère n'est pas complice de
maisons enfants si je fais des actes
c'est vous c'est moi même quand ils
regardent et j'en paie le prix
aujourd'hui et surtout car après tout ça
j'ai quitté le domicile de m donc je
comprends pas vous pouvez maintenant de
moi
j'arrive pas a comprendre a bien sûr
chine qui bien sûr c'est tout à fait
normal surtout qu'elle a des gros
problèmes de santé comme en affaires au
mali au gros maintenant est ce qu'ils
vont nous reloger enfin sur tout ce qui
vole au gir 1 m justement encore je peux
me débrouiller je suis jeune je
travaille et maintenant je travaille
c'est dans le bâtiment
[Musique]
ça t'a donné une leçon t'as plus envie
de faire de conneries tu as envie là
travail est d'aider bien sûr voilà bien
sûr parce que moi je trouve pas que
voilà on peut pas dire oui maintenant on
me venger je vais rocci bien sûr que non
voilà maintenant j'ai mûri j'ai grand
jim ses charmes et de leur guide je vais
recommencer sans je suis assez grand et
je trouve que je pense que j'ai chez
pinsent est probable qu'on sent en moins
sous forme f surtout que la demande est
donc maintenant que je paye on était le
nomma on espère vraiment que ça va
s'arranger pour que maman parce que
c'est l'été passé j'en fais jamais ça
nous fait beaucoup de peine notamment
s'il n'était pas au courant vraiment et
merci d'avoir été avec nous quand même
ce soir merci problème
ça nous fait là
bas salut thomas elle va se retrouver à
la rue et vous avez vu sa mère elle
n'était pas du tout c'est vrai que je
suis pas content je ne suis pas sûr
qu'ils se retrouvent à la rue je peux
pas imaginer que l'objet
ne se met pas on lit à dire c'est
seulement si évidemment il n'y a pas de
il n'y a pas de précédent sur le sujet
en tant que la maman et on n'a pas de
raison de ne pas le penser en tout cas
moi si ça m'arrivait dans la
collectivité je prendrais attache
évidemment avec le préfet le procureur
et le bailleur social pour trouver une
solution pour la maman mais encore une
fois réciprocité entre les droits et les
devoirs à un moment donné faut aussi
prendre ses responsabilités et ce jeune
vient de rappeler alors
été convaincu par le jeune non parce
qu'en fait je rejoigne et passent des
larmoiements en fait ce jeune il est
quand même il a été condamné quoi je
comprends pas que les gens qui sont ici
qui à chaque fois
qu'ils se font
filmer
les thuriféraires et les parangons de
l'état de droit ben là c'est l'état de
droit qui vient de décider de sa
d'accord alors vous pouvez dans l'état
de droit contestées il vous pouvez faire
un recours gracieux faire un recours
devant les tribunaux mais en
l'occurrence si effectivement le juge a
été amené à prendre cette décision et je
rejoins ce qui était dit tout à l'heure
c'est qu'il ya des faisceaux d'éléments
ce type n'est pas une victime c'est
assez dur qui sont en cours 72 familles
dans lesquelles la maman va être viré à
cause des bêtises d'un enfant majeur ça
c'est le début mais ça manque jeunes à
la vie arrive c'était un celi mais n'a
rien volé la tranquille chez les
quartiers n'ont pas à devenir le lieu du
mali du technique de drogue et du deal
bon sens mais d'un moment faut que la
france jugeant merci affaires
interviennent de manière mais après
quelque chose mais cela avait quelque
chose j'en sais rien bouger va-t-il suis
pas au gouvernement bien sûr pas
valablement vous avez proposé quoi a
donc cédé dans les tournois de
généraliser ça justement
vous croyez quoi
lui même ça fait deux générations en
générations qui font du deal dans les
cités c'est quoi la solution c'est à
chaque fois qu'on arrête
de karl olive kamya pas besoin de faire
cinquante mille expulsions pour faire
baisser la délinquance un chez moi c'est
moi à 30% mais on connaît tous les
règles et on est sans cesse à de
[Applaudissements]
la vie m merci aux
personnes assez fou il a beaucoup de ces
concerts non oui j'en remercie m d'avoir
été là c'est vraiment je suis triste que
l'aide soit de ce sondage là bas parce
qu'on pense maintenant à la mer on n'a
même pas de quoi comment elle va vivre
on s'est mis
moi j'assume ce que j'ai fait ma mère
n'a rien à voir avec un taureau comme la
plupart des faux sacs et à insuffler des
prix